foreign it's said that the enigmatic and
counter-intuitive nature of time lies at
the heart of our modern day theories
clocks in different states of motion
tick at different rates
therefore time is relative
but what if there were a completely
different way of looking at things one
surprisingly more mechanistic and
intuitive
indeed something remarkable emerges when
we decide to treat relativity not as a
theory about space
time or kinematics
but rather as a theory about waves
this is dialect with
what time dilation actually is
imagine that you're going to build
yourself a pair of clocks
but these won't be any old clocks rather
special clocks which tick using sound
waves
the concept is simple at one end of the
clock you'd have a detector waiting to
receive a particular sound wave
which upon its arrival would cause that
detector to register a tick of its clock
this detector would then reflect or
re-emit that sound wave back towards a
second detector at the other end of the
clock which would in turn receive it
register another tick and once more
re-emit the wave back
thus with a sound wave continually
passing between the two detectors you'd
have constructed a viable instrument for
measuring the passage of time
[Music]
now you make the following claim using
these clocks you can prove that time is
relative
to do this you keep one clock ticking at
the same location and proceed to fly the
other clock around the world
ideally this flown clock should be as
aerodynamic as possible additionally it
should not be enclosed in any structure
but rather exposed to the open
now when the clocks are reunited you
find that less time has elapsed on the
traveling clock than on the stationary
one
what caused this discrepancy
well the answer is simple
sound waves travel through the medium of
air
and do so always at the same speed the
speed of sound regardless of the speed
of the source which emitted them
this means a sound clock in motion will
function essentially differently from a
sound clock which is at rest
to see this let's label the speed of
sound as C and observe how the ticking
of a sound clock at rest compares to one
in motion
if the distance between the detectors is
D then for a clock at rest with respect
to the air the time it takes a sound
wave to travel that distance will be D
over C
but if the clock is in motion the
distance that the sound wave has to
travel between detectors now becomes
greater than d
meaning it takes a longer amount of time
for the wave to travel that distance and
thus a longer time for the moving clock
to tick
this relationship between ticks on the
two clocks can be easily Quantified via
some simple trigonometry
first four o'clock moving at velocity V
Let's label the distance which the sound
wave has to travel between detectors as
D Prime
now the at rest clock ticks once every D
over C seconds
while the moving clock ticks once every
D Prime over C seconds
the ratio between ticks of the clocks is
thus D Prime over d
we next note that in the time D Prime
over C that it takes the moving clock to
tick
the clock itself will have traversed a
distance V times D Prime over C
we can now see that d d Prime and V
times D Prime over C all form a right
triangle
and thus via the Pythagorean relation we
can express D in terms of D Prime that
is D equals the square root of D Prime
squared minus V times D Prime over c
squared
plugging this expression into our ratio
we can factor out the D Prime in the
denominator and cancel it with the D
Prime in the numerator to leave the
expression 1 divided by the square roots
of 1 minus V squared over c squared
look familiar
well it should because it turns out that
a sound clock in motion with respect to
the air will experience and affect
exactly analogous to that which we
understand in relativity to be the
phenomenon of time dilation
that is the sound clock's rate of
ticking will be slowed down by a factor
determined via the relativistic
expression for gamma
but with C here standing in for the
speed of sound instead of the speed of
light
an awful coincidence right
well the similarities don't end there
for instance let's consider what happens
to two sound clocks that are separated
and then later rejoined
in the earlier example when we flew a
sound clock around the world the clock
which remained stationary with respect
to the air wound up showing more elapsed
time
but now let's say we don't know which
clock is stationary with respect to the
air and which is in motion
[Music]
let's consider two cases first the case
in which the clock that departs travels
away then turns around and returns is
the one which is in motion with respect
to the air
then obviously the stationary clock will
tick faster for the entire duration of
their separation
and so the traveling clock will show
less elapsed time upon the reunion
but now let's consider the second case
wherein both clocks start in motion with
respect to the air
in this case both clocks Begin by
ticking slowly
let's label them clock a and clock B
next clock B abruptly slows down so it
is stationary with respect to the air
while clock a continues traveling off
once stationary clock B will actually
tick faster than its counterpart
however if clock B wants to catch back
up to clock a
it must do so by traveling through the
air at a velocity greater than that with
which clock a is already traveling
so let's say clock B spent five seconds
being stationary with respect to the air
during which clock a traveled away at a
velocity of three-fifths the speed of
sound so that over this duration it
recorded only four elapsed seconds
foreign
next clock B troubles at a velocity of
four-fifths the speed of sound in order
to catch back up to clock a
traveling at this velocity it will take
clock B 20 seconds to catch back up to
clock a
over this duration 16 more seconds will
have elapsed on clock a resulting in the
clock showing 20 total elapsed seconds
but for this same duration only 12
seconds will have elapsed on clock B
resulting in the clock showing only 17
total elapsed seconds
thus when they are reunited the clock
which turned around to catch back up
will still show less elapsed time even
though it was at rest with respect to
the air during some portions of the trip
now we can repeat this experiment
assuming any arbitrary initial
velocities of our sound clocks with
respect to the air and the end result
will always be the same
whichever clock turns around to rejoin
its companion will always end up showing
less elapsed time
this is in consequence of it achieving a
greater total average velocity with
respect to the air over the duration of
its trip
likewise in special relativity we find
that for any two clocks that are
separated and rejoined whichever clock
turned around or accelerated to rejoin
its companion will always end up
recording less elapsed time
unfortunately in special relativity due
to the insistence on preserving the
symmetry of observers differing states
of motion there has never been a clear
consensus on what causes time dilation
you can see that even the experts are
clearly confused by it such as when they
inaccurately claim that only
acceleration causes time dilation
or conflate time dilation with the
Doppler effect
or even bequeath unto time violation the
power of causal agency itself
then of course there are the multitude
of differing interpretations as to what
resolves the twin paradox
but in our soundclock universe something
like the twin paradox becomes
exceedingly simple all we need to do is
Imagine constructing something like say
humanoid robots which operate based off
of sound signals
foreign
functioning in these robots will be
affected by their motion through the air
such that they will experience time
differently depending on that state of
motion
for instance say we construct two robots
that are designed to sprout white hairs
when they turn say 10 seconds old based
on their respective sound clocks
then if we separate and rejoin these
robots we'll find that whichever robot
turns around or accelerates in order to
rejoin its twin will take longer to
sprout its white hairs and thus in
accordance with the results of the twin
paradox wind up being the younger twin
so what does this all mean
well essentially any observable
demonstration of time dilation that we
can make in special relativity can be
mapped to a demonstration of time
dilation in our sound clock universe
this strongly suggests we could invert
such a mapping and interpret relativity
not as some mystical theory about the
altering of space and time but rather as
a theory about how just as sound always
travels at the same speed through the
air light always travels at the same
speed through some sort of medium
this is a model known as dynamical
relativity rooted in lorenz's ether
Theory it was revived in modern form
around the 1980s after drawing
inspiration from the wave mechanics of
quantum physics
but in academic journals it's often
presented as merely a heuristic tool an
aid for intuition for incoming students
as opposed to an actual interpretation
in its own right
of course due to the staunchly
entrenched dogmas of modern physics it's
hard to imagine that such papers would
ever get published were they to present
the idea in any other way
but for the critical thinker the fact
that we can recreate the formalism of
Relativity in a toy universe wherein
information travels via sound waves
instead of light waves should set off
some pretty serious alarm Bells
well okay but you might object that we
haven't recreated the entire formalism
of Relativity just parts of it
indeed let's recap what we have done so
far
first we've shown that time dilation can
be interpreted as a mechanistic effect
of setting clocks in motion relative to
a medium
then we've shown that if you don't know
what your motion is relative to that
Medium no coincident comparisons of
clocks I.E comparisons where clocks have
been separated and then rejoined will
ever reveal it to you
lastly we've shown that if information
itself is assumed to be transmitted
through this medium then this dilation
effect isn't just limited to clocks but
rather extends to anything that relies
on that information for its functioning
if you're familiar with relativity
you've likely already seen time dilation
derived in a mechanistic like
Pythagorean manner for light clocks
before so the first point shouldn't be
too surprising
similarly you're probably already aware
that the speed of light is also
conjectured to be the speed of
information so the third Point shouldn't
reorient your understanding much either
but the second Point gives us something
crucial and new because it offers us a
sort of uncertainty principle for clocks
that is since no clock-based measurement
could ever be used to determine our
motion with respect to the ether this
means there's no way to tell if our
clock is ticking in accordance with true
universal time or if it is ticking at a
dilated rate
meaning it is not time itself which is
relative merely our knowledge of it
now this precipitates an epistemological
conundrum of sorts because any
uncertainty in time-based measurements
will propagate as uncertainty in other
types of measurement
for instance given a known distance
we'll find that any Judgment of velocity
will be subject to the uncertainty of
our time judgment since moving observers
would unknowingly judge their velocities
to be greater
conversely given a known velocity it
then becomes judgments of distance which
suffer this uncertainty
since moving observers traversing such
distances would unknowingly judge them
to be shorter
which brings us round to our essential
conclusion
when we derived gamma for our sound
clocks the V and C stood for velocities
with respect to our medium of air and
subsequently all our use of these
quantities represented measurements that
were certain
but in Einstein's gamma the V and C
stand for velocities with respect to the
Observer not the medium so if any manner
of uncertainty can be shown to have
crept into these values it will reflect
across every other type of measurement
the theory has to offer
indeed it is this clue which will point
us towards unraveling the remaining
mysteries of relativity
Mysteries such as length contraction or
the relativity of simultaneity
placing us just steps away from being
able to give physical intuition to the
entirety of the theory
meaning very soon for the first time we
will be in possession of an
interpretation that doesn't rely on
mathematical abstraction
now a huge shout out here to our patreon
subscribers through whose support we've
been able to bring these recent
Revelations to light
and to all our viewers who have
countenanced our search for real answers
over the years
we hope your excitement for what lies
ahead is as great as ours
this has been dialect stay tuned
foreign